psychologie des enfants est complexe et
nous échappe quelquefois alors pour
mieux cerner cette question nous avons
demandé à françoise dolto d'examiner le
cas de jean christophe pour en tirer des
conclusions plus général sur ces enfants
qui ont besoin
nous écoutons françoise dolto
je crois que on est un petit moment à la
retrouver mais ça ne va pas tarder je
peux vous dire sans me tromper qu'elle
arrive pas heureux mais vous savez il ya
beaucoup d'enfants dans les familles
aussi qui ne sont pas heureux lui il
sait pourquoi il n'est pas heureux c'est
parce qu'il n'est pas dans son foyer et
je crois que le travail ce serait de
leur faire une liste d'adressés l'enfant
pourrait retrouver des gens qu'il a aimé
petit une nourrice des camarades
une monitrice de colonies de vacances
des parrains des grands-mères je ne sais
pas quelque chose ils chercheraient et
puis deux ou trois parrainage mais pas
un seul je crois que c'est ça qui est
mauvais c'est encore de subir une
personne qui veut bien s'occuper d'un
petit garçon non lui donner des adresses
de ferme qui prennent trois ou quatre
enfants dans la région
tiens voilà voilà tel ou tel ou tel
endroit tu pourrais aller il faut que tu
leur écrivent pour leur dire que tu
voudrais y aller tel jour et convenir ça
avec eux c'est pas nous qui veut qu
allons le faire
c'est possible mais c'est à toi tu te
mettre en acte accordé avec leur
téléphone ou leur écrits de riez puis à
partir de 8 ans il se dit aussi bien
dans une famille que dans un foyer qui
est un substitut familiale oui en fait
il faut éviter d'en faire des assistés
oui il faut que l'enfant puisse prendre
des initiatives et pour cela le choix
des initiatives dans des lieux prévus
et s'ils ne sont pas prévues contrôler
et c'est ainsi que l'enfant apprend à
vivre que ce soit dans une famille il
ose un foyer je crois que c'est la même
chose alors c'est là je crois c'est
intéressant un enfant musiciens pourrait
sortir chez des gens musiciens un enfant
qui aime les musées chez quelqu'un qui a
un enfant qui aime le bricolage mais pas
du tout c'est ce qu'on peut faire dans
une famille pas utopique puisque ça se
fait dans les familles qui y voit un
enfant tient il est intéressé au moteur
je vais le chercher
vous cherchez un mécanicien qui voudra
bien que tu y ailles de mercredi
après-midi à partir de 12 ans c'est
comme ça que les enfants ont passé leurs
loisirs
un enfant qui dit à 10 ans j'en ai marre
mais il est triste ils le disent tout le
temps dans la famille j'en ai marqué
c'est pas vrai il y en a marre ça
minutes après ils rigolera mais non mais
non c'est bien qu'ils puissent dire j'en
ai marre vous ne dites jamais j'en ai
marre même quand vous êtes heureuse ça
ne veut rien dire on ne peut pas être
égal toujours contents il n'y a pas de
lieu comme ça s'il n'y a pas de tension
y a pas d'avenir non plus on ne cherche
pas à s'en sortir
la psychanalyste françoise dolto est
morte hier à l'âge de 79 ans avec autant
de simplicité que de chaleur elle avait
su faire entrer la psychanalyse dans
notre vie quotidienne et nous faire
comprendre entre autres que l'éducation
des enfants ce n'était ni le laisser
aller ni les grands coups de yaka mais
une oeuvre d' écoute de bon sens et
d'amour annie-claude elkaïm avec
françoise dolto c'est l'une des plus
grandes figures de la psychanalyse en
france qui disparaît aujourd'hui l'une
des plus grandes l'une des plus
populaires aussi par ses ouvrages par
ces émissions et par sa pratique
quotidienne de psychanalyste pour
enfants dont elle était une des
pionnières
elle avait toute sa vie durant avec son
parler clair et son souci du faire
savoir le vrai pour la cause des enfants
et les parents voudraient que leurs
enfants soient soit la réussite totale
qu'il ne soit jamais malheureux or un
enfant qui serait jamais malheureuse ce
n'est pas un être humain un être humain
ne peut pas ne pas être malheureux mais
s'il peut exprimer à quelqu'un qui ne va
pas tomber malheureux parce qu'il va le
lui exprimer mais qui va l'aider à
dépasser ce malheur et en tirer une
expérience alors il fait office de
parent qui aide son enfant à assumer les
épreuves les épreuves d'un être humain
sur terre qui n'arrivera jamais à se
faire comprendre par un autre jamais
jamais à travers nombre de ses ouvrages
c'est cette vie quotidienne que
françoise dolto a analysé y compris dans
les derniers d'entre elles venaient à
peine de les terminer
l'un d'eux était consacrée à sa propre
enfance
dans la vie de tous les jours quelle
genre de personnalités tel travail
extraordinaire d'une enfin d'une
optimisme absolument fantastique d'une
vitalité inwi est toujours très tard
comme on dit a toujours prête à
encourager
elle avait d'ailleurs ça en commun avec
lacan en encourager les autres à faire
des choses il faut dire qu'elle
pénétrait dans un studio de radio
je me souviens des années 80 a été
beaucoup plus dynamique que nous elle
nous pousse et en toutes choses en face
d'eux le taux donc qui par parenthèse et
est aussi la mère du chanteur carlos ils
avaient tous les deux d'ailleurs des
relations très proches
françoise dolto qui a marqué je vous le
disais tout à l'heure la psychanalyse
ces travaux faisait autorité sa fille
qui elle même a suivi ses traces a
expliqué alain labouze l'importance de
ces travaux écouter elle était
merveilleuse
c'était l'été elle était bonne et est
intelligente elle était drôle mais était
généreuse j'étais toujours un travail
dans sa tête toujours à s'occuper des
autres
même quand elle était très malade pour
ceux qui la connaissaient pas bien
qu'est ce qu'elle a apporté
or je crois tellement de choses que je
suis bien incapable de le dire surtout
maintenant je crois que l a quand même
marqué un tournant dans l'histoire de la
façon dont on conçoit le psychisme des
gens et puis dans ton compte que la
place des enfants le respect des enfants
je crois que je crois que si elle si
elle voulait laisser un message c'était
respecter les enfants plus que et mais
qui veut pas forcément dire grand chose
pour que c'était surtout le mot respect
récemment elle s'était énervé à propos
des des histoires des droits des enfants
parce qu'elle visait mais enfin on parle
pas des devoirs aussi on parle que des
droits mais il ya le devoir d et des
éducateurs des géniteurs
et puis si on parle à quelqu'un de ses
droits il faut toujours lui parler de
ses devoirs ya trois jours encore elle
écrit une préface
oui ça a été son dernier plaisir pour
justement parce que c'était une préface
pour une une juge pour enfants québécois
ce qui a une éthique dans son abord des
enfants qui est merveilleuse et c'était
très important pour elle de soutenir ça
parce que l'été très très soucieuse du
sort des enfants quand les adultes se
disputent autour de la mort de françoise
dolto f-cell que l'on avait surnommé la
grand-mère de la psychanalyse avait 79
ans influencé par jacques lacan elle
était l'une des meilleures spécialistes
de la psychologie de l'enfant par ses
ouvrages ses émissions de radio
elle avait su mettre à la portée du plus
grand nombre ces méthodes d'approché de
compréhension du monde de l'enfance à
nana booth
ce sont les enfants qui ont une
curiosité extraordinaire et une
curiosité qui n'est pas seulement de ce
qu'il voit mais de ce qu'il perçoit
avaient ils perçoivent très finement au
toucher et à l'audition
ils perçoivent les nuances de la voix de
quelqu'un qui leur parle juste ou faux
et c'est pour ça que c'est si important
que les parents ne répète pas les
paroles qu'on leur dit qu'il faut dire
aux enfants parce qu'ils s'entendent
très bien que c'est dû répéter que ce
n'est pas de leur cru mais quand vous
commencez à parler à des bébés comme si
c'était comme s'ils allaient pouvoir
vous répondre
on a dû quand même beaucoup se moquer de
vous oui il était un peu la za de
service on
on s'amusait de me voir parler avec les
enfants c'est ici dans ce bureau que
pendant 40 ans françoise dolto a appris
le langage des enfants pour mieux le
faire partager à leurs parents mais
aussi parce que pour elle une seule
cause compter celles des enfants
pédiatre et psychanalyste françoise
dolto avait la passion de l'écriture
elle a reçu ici rue saint jacques
des milliers de parents souvent
désemparés ce qu'elle voulait avant tout
que le monde de l'enfance ne soit plus
étranges et aux adultes
il a quand même marqué un tournant dans
l'histoire de la façon dont on conçoit
le psychisme des gens et puis dans ton
contre la place des enfants le respect
d'un fond je crois que je crois que si
elle si elle voulait laisser un message
c'était respecter les enfants et
quelques jours elle a failli te disais
que tu m'as pour les queues
et que cette expérience avait avait
renforcé non seulement sans plaisir de
bien vivre ses derniers moments et dans
le calme de la tombe de haut
[Musique]